eric faces the giants now for only the
second time in his career well welcome
back eric fetty
last outing was on may 16th
so right on time at 205 here comes the
first one
and swinging and singling as lamont wade
the university of maryland product goes
out to center where andrew stevenson is
playing today
that'll bring up mike yostremski two
balls and two strikes fetty delivers and
a swing and a miss struck him out with a
cut fastball at 90 miles an hour well
here's the cutter up yeah a little
wonder swaro action on that one here
comes the guy who's the key to the
giants lineup right now buster posey 2-2
nats looking for a grounder instead it's
a changer and eric fetty had buster
bosey way out in front two now now the
nets are in a shift for brandon belt
three and two there goes wade the pitch
and it's in there strike three called on
a cutter locks up brandon belt and the
side retired
it has been a while since gosman was
last out on the mound one week ago today
and there's a long one to right
by a leadoff man with power
c
you later dwarver lands in section 239
with plenty of room to spare this is
what davey martinez was looking for out
of the lead off spot today by sliding
cars over up to the first
absolute bomb first three nationals have
reached base safely against gospel josh
bell switch hitter the pitch is hit on
the ground to second flores has it flips
to second one crawford to first double
play on the play turner goes to third
josh bell hit that pretty hard but right
into the defense for the double play
ball two down one-two pitch is swung on
him strike three the splitter got him
posey reaches out at tags harrison
bosman gets his first strikeout so
gosman to face starling castro here's
the pitch from gausman it is swung on it
missed strength three got him with the
split finger pitch out number one second
strikeout in a row for
grossman
that one got by buster posey
in time nice bit of footwork there by
brandon belt shifting from one foot to
the other to get the throw and keep the
foot in the bag kevin gausman he does
have four hits for the year
that's a base hit to left field
such that's a really really good at bat
worked the count worked the count saw
some off speed pitches got some pitches
out of fetty and gets jammed just enough
but gets enough barrel on it to just
dump it out in the left field here is
jastremski with the tying run gauzeman
at second
fair ball pouncing mavilla high throw
josh bell had to put his
tippy toes up on the bag good thing he's
a tall first baseman check swing and
it's off the wrist of bell time to
recover
mr posey not able to get down the line
quickly enough and josh bell kept his
wits about him the pitcher did his job
and the nats are out of the inning
kyle schwarber who launched a big home
run to lead off for the nats
owen won the count
that's deep to right field
yastrimsky at the wall
not this time out off the end of the bat
on that off speed pitch husband's 1-2
pitch
here it is and it's popped up
behind first belt ranging over into foul
ground and he's underneath it to make
the catch
that is out number three very good
inning for
kevin gausman it's gonna be branded belt
leading off the frame
swing and a miss on the cutter
eric fetty with an effective cut
fastball to some lefties today
yeah the last time he had a strikeout
was against brandon dalton here's
brandon crawford the 2-2
swing and a miss struck him out with a
cutter to the inside that has been
fetty's strikeout pitch this inning to
the left-handed batters bottom of the
fourth bell bats here with no outs and
one on see if he goes with the splitter
now
one two he does and he struck him out
swinging
great arm action the dive on that pitch
it's just by the time you recognize it
those are the swings you end up seeing
out of it so here's harrison josh struck
out his first time up harrison hits one
a ton the other way
this one heading for the track and it
short hops the wall it checks up soto
coming around he will score easily
and josh harrison opposite field puts
the nats up by two
great swing by josh harrison i said he
was not going to wait around for another
splitter from kevin gossman jumped on
this fast spot out over the plate
went with the pitch and as you mentioned
before bob the sun's starting to come
out a little bit you see you scrambled
the shrimp kind of pull up on that as
that ball went into the sun a little bit
to not allow them to make the catch
there juan soto hustling all the way
around
love to see it so here's talkman
left-handed batter facing fetty
swang and a miss
a couple of nasty curveballs to a
left-handed batter took the air out of
those swings number six for eric fetty
well mike talkman a little sword action
here with this half swing
definitely wasn't anticipating that
breaking ball with six strikeouts now
for eric fetty stephen duggar over two
career against fetty two-two
swing and a miss on the curveball
eric fenney had all of his weapons
working today
seven strikeouts he's going to get a
nice ovation on his way to the dugout
and that's on top two nothing six outs
to get first three of those the
responsibility of kyle finnegan the
right fielder mike
with the shift on it's one and two
and again yostremski the other way this
would be close down there
in andrew stevenson with enough room to
make the grab
huge out
with buster posey coming up
and posie will drop one into right
center
to extend his hitting streak to six
games
buster
12 for 26 buster pull his hands on the
inside of this elevated sinker and the
only reason why that ball stayed up in
the air just because it started up so
two out runner at first
swing
and a miss
they struck him out with a 97 mile an
hour fastball and the side retired belt
has struck out all three times to the
plate right hand is coming on try and
close out game one of this day night
split day h with the score the nationals
two of the giants nothing
swing and a miss
on a big breaking ball the patented brad
hand fighter starts behind the
left-handed batters they're just not
able to stay on it and see crawford
well
out in front of that one as he was
reaching trying to foul it off wilmer
flores with a homer and two rbis against
bret hand career two for six
he'll go the other way
juan soto is there two down on a
one-pitch hour outfielder austin slater
from the right side
and he's going to get a cold first
strike with it to end the game
which will take about two hours and 10
minutes
and now the gnats return the shutout
favor to the giants